everyone everyone I know everyone I know
in uh in Tokyo they just agree that fing
m is the worst there's a lot of
arguments over 7-Eleven and Lawson's but
I think family m is the worst well
family M chicken for sure is the worst
like that is all their food selection is
[__] yeah but you know 7-Eleven the
smoothies those are [__] Godlike you
can buy these smoothies in 7-Eleven
where it's like you get out of the
freezer it's yeah I saw Tik Tok yeah
yeah yeah I saw a Tik Tok I went to the
[__] store and I no no no I saw I saw
a Tik Tok where some guy was like this
is why Japan is living in make a [__]
smoothie yeah this right yeah I I saw I
saw Tik Tok where it was like this is
why Japan is living in the
future because they have
blenders because they have blenders get
the [__] pink one it's strawberry soy
and it's [__] Godlike it's got like
like a bunch of protein too it's 100
calories it tastes so [__] good get
it it's so good it is very convenient I
do love aw CU like I you know sometimes
I want to drink but I don't want a
coffee and I just want something that's
refreshing
and it's 200 in the summer as well
especially cuz it comes out of the
freezer as well like yeah it's so nice
they're constantly upping it like I
genuinely think every time I've left
Japan now I'm like man I don't think I
can ever leave Japan like I don't think
I I can ever live anywhere else yeah com
are too strong here yeah it made me I
may I realized this even going to Korea
and I'm like Comin game we compared to
Japan I don't know if I could uh I don't
know if I could live it and their Comin
compared to like Tesco or something is
still [__] god tier but uh Japan
companies are just another level a lot
of people always like when you going to
move to LA Conor or something I'm like
no I I I literally just can't leave
Japan it's it's too good I'm too I I
like my I like my life too much day by
day it's you Uber send for everything
anyway Conor yeah that's great yeah but
I love walking around it's it's great
because we can always tell I can I can
now tell how often Connor uses Uber cuz
we have a company card okay I fixed it
now I fix we have a company card and
Conor did not realize that he was using
his personal Uber orders on the company
car what the [__] I never agreed to this
I reimbursed you guys I reimbursed you
guys all right I'm a man of my word okay
so I giving this man free meals for no
no I reimbursed it I gave the money back
so I remember I was just chilling and I
get this notification being like you uh
your your card has uh been charged for
Uber and I was like wait uh none of the
boys are here I'm at home why why who's
using Uber right now and I log on to the
app that we all have and I scroll down
and there's like five Uber e orders all
marked to Connor 5 days in a row and I'm
like Connor what the [__] mate our boss
is shock all right I love going out he
says no I love walking around but in
terms of like meals I feel like I still
don't often like I won't just stop at a
place and eat normally I I I've been
walking a lot around lately even if it's
like an hour and a half walk I'm like
[__] it I'll walk why not yeah
cuz I want I love doing this now I just
walk to a place and when I'm passing
places that look cool I'll look them up
on Google and I'll see the pictures of
the food and how it is and I'll be like
okay I'm saving this I'm going here uh
and then he goes home and order to yeah
I don't want to eat out all the time
right because I want to most like so so
you eat out in yeah well it's salad most
of the time I'm just [__] ordering a
salad it's boring uh you know Su it's a
shame I felt bad cuz I messaged Conor
when he was like live on stream or some
[__] and I was like yo can you uh I
think you've been charging the company
card for your for your all your orders
cuz I got the notification too I was
like [__] like yeah I know continues to
play there nothing I could do at the
moment you know the burrito was
coming it's all good it was a good
burrito though H so it's the end of the
year you guys are ready for next year no
I've not heard a single person say
they're excited for
2024 just what what is there to be
excited about nothing I mean people are
optimistic I feel like Co removed
optimism for like hoping for the next
New Year we still like we're still
recovering from Co like we are people
are just the world is not well adjusted
still it's not the same man it's not the
same I mean I feel like before people
were more optimistic they like yeah this
year is going to be my year and I don't
know if the world just got a lot more
pessimistic but uh I think the world has
got more pessimistic I especially after
you know so many of them had to
experience the horrors of Co right like
you know it'd be it's pretty like it's
pretty difficult to just tell someone
like you know you were locked in the
house for like 3 and a half years but it
gets better don't worry it's like you
know hard to believe for some people
there's there's there's two sides of
this where it's like all right if I'm
like if I was in school right during Co
I I get like two [__] years of schooling
maybe three of like just schooling that
as crap CU I'm on Zoom right and then uh
maybe I I graduate or something
especially if you're around graduating
time this is Dreadful you go to the
workforce like oh by the way uh also
your your country everyone's getting old
and you're going to have to pay like
double the tax your elders paid you
can't afford a house rip it's like okay
well [__] I guess what is there to be
excited for like I'm I'm literally told
that it is going to get worse for me um
but on the other hand I'm like GTA 6
though yeah on the other hand on the
other hand GTA 6 yo GTA 6 though Persona
3 reload though [__] H games H TV
shows but then but then I can't even get
excited about hype TV shows or games
because there was a writers strike this
year and actor strike so that in like 4
years we're going to get like [__]
Lost season 4 and Prison Break season 3
all over again where every TV gets
suffered now because of the rider strike
um so it's like all right well great so
[__] not there's like not a lot to
look forward to yeah um AI is getting
worse um it's a pretty good time to be
miserable if you were betting on that I
don't I I feel okay what do you think do
you think there's going to be a new tech
fad next year I swear to God every year
now there is some new tech F A is going
to be like the next big thing for the
next like 10 years no AI is going to
likee like Prevail going to be the
biggest it's it's only going to get
bigger and more prevalent I totally
agree with that but maybe like AR B
potentially because like the year before
we had [__] nfts
and bring him back that's my child yeah
like the year like the year before last
uh was it like I think it was last year
we had nfts and then before that it was
like Bitcoin uh then this year was like
AI where people were like losing their
[__] I swear to
like Tech Bros find a thing a new thing
to get excited about every single year I
swear it's going to be like that AR [__]
you know after they after Apple announce
like those goggle things like Tech Bros
are going to be all over that and you're
going to be like augmented reality is is
the future it's going to up our
productivity it's going to make
everything so you know safe for people
blah blah blah and it's like it's just
going to be another fad like it always
has unless I'm wrong and this ages like
milk but you know so far the track
record hasn't been great you know people
saying the same thing about nfts 3 years
ago and look what happened to that yeah
I mean the some of these ideas sound
very exciting you know I AI I think we
just need to figure out what the line is
between what's ethical and what's not
because people are going to use it
either way shape or form right totally
uh hey is the Apple Vision coming out
next year uh fck when's it coming out I
think it's next year right or it's
2025 yeah when's it when's it coming
out but that's just porn for rich people
you know what I
mean early early 2024
yeah holy [__] I'm not paying 4K to
watch porn I'm just not like that's
that's disgusting well he can you can do
that with uh any [__] VR system right
do you can do that with an Oculus too
you it does need to be the I tried
watching porn VR one time cuz I was
interested to see how it was and I was
like this is a horrible experience yeah
this is like motion sickness meets
[__] it doesn't even look good either
no it does it's all like warped and [__]
like all right I I I got like I got to
ask I which point does your mate come
like come home with like a purchase he
does that but also comes home with a
purchas and you're like all right we got
to have a talk we got to have an
intervention here because I saw I saw
this tweet the other day I'm going to
see if I can find but it was like it was
this [__] own hole that was basically
uh that was basically strapped on to a
jackhammer that's almost an auto Jacker
yeah so it was like an auto Jacker that
would just that that where that you
would hold like you were you they you
would hold handles and you would it
would [__] jackhammer your dick off
right and then the Tweet was women be
careful or something women like women be
aware and and and at that point you at
that point you got to be like all right
how far is too far man how far how far
do we have to go before you have to have
an intervention you know what I uh I
respect that I I do this series where I
review my viewers rooms right and
somebody had like uh a bust it was like
a torso that had a hole at the bottom so
it was like a it was like a a torso of a
woman that you could you know do things
to yeah and I think that's too far gone
like like well like like here to here uh
like here to like leg area oh okay so
the hole was in the normal spot yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh okay okay so like you
it was like you would you you know you
were doing it but I I felt like that's
too far but it had no head no arms no no
no but I feel like that like if you are
having sex with that you are there's
something wrong I don't see what's the
problem with just using your hand if I'm
being honest you know but I feel like if
you're buying that [__] around it I'm
like come on man like yeah this we
should be investing elsewhere all I
found the Tweet the Tweet is I will
forget you exist and this
no I've seen that before you've seen
that before I've seen this [__] that's
actually and there's a phone holder at
the top there's a phone holder at the
top so you got a there is definitely no
way I can show this on uh YouTube but
yeah it's you can you can show that you
you can show can I show this I think you
can show that so good all right I'll I
guess I'll send you the link gu uh for
you to show mood on it like I think like
theoretically it's like yeah that stuff
could work but it's like when you buy
[__] like that or make that you're like
resigning yourself to you're like well
I'm just this is going to be my life
yeah pretty much I I feel I mean you at
that point you will forget that girls
exist because uh girls can't provide
that kind of same convenience as this uh
holder Jackhammer that Jacks you off at
the same time you know that's what the
take Bros are going to be on next year
that's that's the new that's the new
thing we're going to be scared of it's
just like the apocalypse is happening
birth rate is going down humanity is
going extinct and there's nothing we can
do about it cuz everyone's busy going to
be like one uping each other being like
mine's got a six piston Well mine's got
an eight piston got a V8 in it
[Laughter]
V8 I'm try thisat mine's got a 4080
inside of it
oh my God yeah uh I don't know honestly
like I feel like the past couple of
years when like I guess the the term
Tech bro especially was kind of starting
to come into relevance uh in the
mainstream I guess uh like I had no clue
every single year it was it was kind of
a game for me to be like what is it
going to be this time and uh let's just
say I didn't see nfts coming I didn't
see nfts coming no I don't no I called
the them making one piece remake I told
I I said it on the podcast they're going
to remake one piece
when they were done with one piece I
said when they were done though they're
not even done with it but I I called
they were going to remake it and they
did but they were F they jumped the
[__] gun they were like [__] it let's
do it now they got to capitalize on a
while it's hot right but yeah I think
jacking off to a jackhammer probably not
good for your mental even if even if I
think your mental is a bit
far like you should do that if you if
you own a a [__] [__] doll at
home get rid of it get rid of it just
use your hand bro please for your own
sake yeah it's it's no different from
watching yes it is you bought a
humanized [__] toy it is very different
no get rid of it even the Tanger video
that we did some of the Contraptions
that they like brought out for us are
[__] absur they're monetizing your
loneliness yeah you are lonely and they
are taking advantage of you by saying
hey look what you need you know cuz I
see some of these Contraptions and at
that point it kind of just feels like
you're just hacking the mind to find the
most efficient way to jack off yeah and
uh unfortunately uh if you've never been
you know if you've never had partner
before you know that you know sex isn't
the most efficient thing of all time you
know it it actually takes a lot of work
a lot of times it's a workout two pumps
of me
G I just have to look at a
woman to Papa done that's what they call
me you to my
eyes was that [__] Mana where he's
like the guy with like the touch I can't
remember the name of it oh yeah yeah
yeah uh [__] what was what was the name
of it again oh [__] it's my favorite
mama oh it's such a good Mana I can't
remember it though uh golden not golden
boy
uhy that's something else Golden Touch I
don't know yeah